pensé que debía ser un vídeo para
aclarar algunos puntos sobre la
evolución y a lo mejor aclarar algunos
puntos que quedaron ambiguos en algunos
de los vídeos anteriores cuando vas a un
museo de historia natural ves estos
dibujos que empiezan con un simio
primitivo y muestran especies que
progresan lo que demuestran algún tipo
de progreso en lo que se refiere a
caminar en dos pies y culmina con el
homo sapiens sapiens que somos nosotros
y uno se imagina que la evolución es
como un proceso que crea cosas cada vez
mejores uno imagina que hay una noción
de progreso que al pasar el tiempo cada
especie sucesiva es mejor que la primera
y quiero que quede claro que esta noción
de mejora en realidad no tiene sentido
en el contexto evolutivo o en el
contexto de la selección natural que lo
único que importa es la aptitud o la
capacidad de adaptación al entorno o la
frecuencia con la que uno es capaz de
reproducirse en su medio ambiente lo
cual no necesariamente concuerda con
nuestra noción de mejora
algunas personas piensan cuál será el
siguiente paso en la evolución humana y
se imaginan humanos con un cerebro más
grande que pueden mover objetos con su
energía mental y que pueden ver a través
de objetos y así se imaginan algún tipo
de progreso en el que si ahora somos más
inteligentes y podemos hacer todas estas
cosas que los simios no podían a lo
mejor en la próxima fase evolutiva habrá
algún tipo de súper humano y yo no sé
cuál será la siguiente fase evolutiva si
es que hay una siguiente fase evolutiva
ni entrar en ese debate pero la idea es
que eso no es necesariamente lo que va a
suceder el éxito en términos evolutivos
es muy distinto al éxito como es
definido socialmente por ejemplo digamos
que hay dos personas este chico tiene un
doctorado en filosofía y un doctorado en
medicina y tiene mucho dinero es decir
tiene todo lo que la sociedad define que
una persona exitosa tiene y como tienen
dos doctorados ha estado en la escuela
por mucho tiempo y él
y de no tener hijos ya que quieres ser
muy responsable y se fije en la
población mundial y la sobrepoblación y
el impacto en el medio ambiente y
digamos que él y su esposa la cual
también tiene un doctorado en filosofía
y un doctorado en medicina y tiene mucho
dinero y títulos y ha pasado mucho de su
tiempo en la escuela deciden tener un
hijo un hijo
esta es su esposa ella tiene una
educación similar y desde nuestro punto
de vista son muy exitosos una pareja muy
responsable ahora digamos que hay otra
persona por acá y él ha sido una persona
muy irresponsable tuvo un hijo tras otro
digamos que para cuando cumple 30 años
él ya tiene 10 hijos y todos son de
madres distintas a lo mejor algunos de
los niños tuvieron que ser dados en
adopción quien sabe la situación de esta
persona y no quiero juzgar su vida pero
la idea en general es que en la sociedad
diríamos que este chico es menos exitoso
pero desde el punto de vista de la
evolución
este chico es mucho más exitoso de hecho
para personas como él la frecuencia de
sus genes está creciendo mucho más
rápidamente que la frecuencia de los
genes de estas personas así que cuando
hablamos de la aptitud desde un punto de
vista evolutivo no es necesariamente
actitud desde el punto de vista del que
nos gusta pensar regularmente es decir
desde el sistema de valores que tenemos
en la sociedad estas personas tienen
buenas aptitudes intelectuales
sabe a la mejor también físicas pero no
se están reproduciendo sus genes no
están siendo transmitidos con la misma
frecuencia que la de esta persona no
recuerdo bien el dato estadístico pero
hay como un 80 por ciento de personas en
asia que tienen genes de un solo hombre
que vivió en los años 1200 y es
probablemente de un guerrero de mongolia
como gengis khan o kublai khan pero eso
demuestra que algunas personas y no
estoy haciendo ningún juicio aquí pero
pudo haber existido personas muy
agresivas personas que pueden haber
violado o saqueados sociedades completas
y que fueron muy exitosos desde un punto
de vista evolutivo aun cuando pensemos
que sus actos fueron despreciables pero
lo que quiero es darte la idea de que no
hay necesariamente un sentido de
progreso si este patrón que he descrito
aquí sigue ocurriendo entonces este tipo
de personas se volvería cada vez menos y
menos frecuente en el acervo genético y
esta persona se volvería más y más
frecuente en el acervo genético así es
que probablemente
terminaríamos con una población humana
más agresiva o entre comillas menos
responsable así es que quiero aclarar
que la evolución o la selección natural
no es tan solo una serie de pasos
progresivos en los cuales lentamente nos
volvemos o cualquier organismo se vuelve
un animal mejor o más inteligente o más
rápido sólo depende de su entorno y para
que está siendo seleccionado ahora otra
cosa que quisiera aclarar es algunos de
los puntos que se hicieron en el vídeo
acerca del diseño inteligente en este
vídeo la intención no fue la de comparar
el diseño inteligente y la evolución así
es que tenemos evolución en este lado
y tenemos diseño inteligente en este
lado y quisiera aclarar ya lo mejor no
se aclaró bien en ese vídeo que este
debate es artificial la evolución es en
realidad la base de la biología moderna
si quisieras entender cómo funciona la
gripe o si quisieras entender el genoma
humano o si quisieras entender la
herencia genética la evolución es la
piedra angular de todo esto y no está
completa cada día cada año descubrimos
más y más sobre cómo funciona el proceso
de selección natural aún hay debate 5
incluso si las personas aún no están
seguras del ritmo al que ocurre la
evolución o si hay otros factores que
pueden agilizar la o ralentizar la pero
quiero ser muy clara esto sí explica
todas nuestras observaciones o
pongámoslo de esta manera todas nuestras
observaciones en la ciencia moderna
sustentan la evolución y la selección
natural y es la base de la biología
moderna así es que si uno fuese a
desmentir la selección natural y la
estarían en realidad desmintiendo
nuestro entendimiento de la biología
moderna el diseño inteligente es un
sistema de creencias y mi punto detrás
de esto es tratar de reconciliar las
facciones que favorecen esta idea con la
idea de la evolución para que ellos
puedan reconciliar las ideas religiosas
sin tener que desmentir lo que es la
piedra angular de la biología moderna y
cuando habla de diseño insisto en que en
vez de ver un diseño en particular ya
sea el del ojo o el de un organismo en
particular incluso recalcó que no hay un
diseño en particular incluso si se
observa el ojo humano no hay una sola
versión del ojo humano hay un número
infinito de variaciones del ojo humano
así es que debería de ser diseños
inteligentes y no diseño inteligente
pero mi punto detrás de este vídeo es el
de querer decir que si tú te inclinas
por creer en un diseñador entonces el
diseño más elegante está al nivel del
sistema el cual es en realidad la
evolución
ahora no estaba tratando de decir que
hay un diseñador o que no hay un
diseñador solo decía que si te inclinas
por creer en uno esto es más profundo y
hace más justicia al diseñador en el
cual te inclinas en creer esto no es
ciencia en lo absoluto el diseño
inteligente es una negación de todo lo
que la ciencia moderna nos dice hoy y no
es una teoría como algunos de sus
partidarios proponen y lo envuelven en
términos que suenan científicos pero no
es una teoría no se puede poner a prueba
el diseño inteligente no hay información
que confirme o desmienta que de alguna
manera algo fue diseñado por algún tipo
de creador esto es sólo un sistema de
creencias que esencialmente rechaza esto
pero no quiero faltarle el respeto a
aquellos que creen en este sistema de
creencias ya que parte de creencias muy
arraigadas mi objetivo en realidad es
reconciliar eso y si tú quieres darle a
tu creencia mayor crédito sería mejor
que mirar hasta el sistema en lugar de
ver al diseño
solo quería recalcar esos dos puntos dos
aclaraciones uno sobre el debate entre
la evolución y el diseño inteligente que
en realidad no es un debate ya que la
evolución es la piedra angular de la
biología moderna y el diseño inteligente
es algo que simplemente rechaza eso y no
es una teoría probable irrefutable
además quiero recalcar el punto de que
la evolución no necesariamente implica
una dirección clara de progreso hacia
criaturas cada vez más inteligentes e
impresionantes